[Music]
over the past several weeks we've
brought you stories that shine a light
on heart health as part of american
heart month today we have a story that's
a little closer to home for us here at
cbs mornings andy murlis is one of our
veteran and very beloved producers and
10 years ago at 46 years old he had a
heart attack he says he was blindsided
by the event and didn't recognize the
signs it's a common theme our dr tara
narula sat down with andy to give us a
look at what those closed-door
conversations with your doctor can look
like good morning tara good morning
adriana so full disclosure here i am
also now andy's cardiologist and i asked
him if he'd be willing to share his
story with us not because it's an
exceptional story but because it's a
typical one one that i see all the time
andy is one of the six hundred thousand
men each year who suffer from a heart
attack or fatal coronary heart disease
getting him to open up wasn't easy but i
hope everyone watching takes a close
listen
i had no idea that anything was was
brewing right and i was in atlantic city
with jeff galore to cover superstorm
sandy good morning to you and we have
seen the rain and wind pick up
significantly here in atlantic city and
coming home i remember just how
exhausted i was like a level of
exhaustion i hadn't felt before that
next tuesday was the election night for
the second obama term and i remember i
worked overnight and then when i woke up
thursday morning i woke up with a
searing pain
right in the middle of my chest
i didn't know what it was but i don't
think i'm atypical of men in this world
who just think i'll get over it did you
think it could be your heart or
something serious i don't remember
having that thought
until
i was on my way to the er i walked 10
blocks to the er while having a heart
attack which i didn't realize so you
still didn't think it was serious enough
that you should be calling an ambulance
having said i'm driving very cheap so i
didn't want to pay for an ambulance like
i would crawl then they did some blood
work and then i looked up from my bed
and the attending physician was walking
towards me at a very rapid pace and she
came she said and that it was a heart
attack they were going to rush me right
up to uh to uh catheterization and get
in get a couple of stems now i was
scared i was thinking about you know i
had three kids at home my girls were
seven and my son was 11. so they were
young
and both my grandfathers died of heart
attacks you know those things start to
go through your head and how old were
you at this point i was 46. i just
didn't think 46 year olds get heart
attacks i looked back at pictures of me
from then and i was a gelatinous mess
and i didn't realize that but like i was
much heavier than i am now i was out of
shape so you had two stents placed into
one artery in your heart correct you
mentioned the stress of working as a
producer at cbs news for so many years
obviously it took a physical toll but
what about the emotional or mental toll
of the kind of work that you do we tell
some stories that are tough to tell i
don't think that even to this day i
acknowledge what that might have done to
me i think that we sort of
compartmentalized that but the one thing
i didn't tackle for years was the
stressors and also one of my children is
pretty profoundly autistic so there's a
lot of stress with a special needs child
in terms of just day-to-day living and
her sleep habits are terrible so for
many years i wasn't getting any sleep so
that added a lot of stress too so you're
constantly on high alert yeah you're
just you're there's no there's no
exhaling and so you came to see me in
2018. you told me you were going to be
preparing to run the empire state
building right you said it's been a
while since we've seen inside your
arteries we should do that but they
found it was like an 80 blockage in a
much more profoundly important artery
this was an event there could have been
much more serious than the one i had and
throughout it all you have not lost your
sense of humor no no in fact i used to
do stand-up comedy
i made i made some good mileage out of
my heart attack i recently had a heart
attack
it was not fatal
making people laugh and laughing
yourself is just wonderful it's such a
release and you know it also keeps you
from taking yourself too seriously so
after your heart attack what kinds of
changes did you make in your life the
first changes i made were diet and
exercise and i've the biggest change
i've made you know in that regard is
that i don't look back and regret things
like
because regret is waste what i've
learned to do is to take
things that i cannot control and stop
obsessing over them stop worrying about
them i think i'm a lot less cynical than
i once was so you're training for a half
marathon
i'm now training for this half marathon
but there's nothing i can do about what
happened in the past so
except for learn the lessons of that
right and so that meant doing everything
i can
to prevent it from happening against you
know eating better staying in shape life
is a lot more fragile than you think
people would say you got to get some
sleep i don't sleep when i'm dead and
then when you like realize that maybe
you were closer to sleeping than you
knew
what do you hope that people who are
listening take away from this
conversation what i think is important
is that
you do your best to recognize what's
going on in your life and take charge of
it where you can
but just because i had a heart attack
doesn't mean
that it's all over in fact it's quite
the opposite you can come back from
problems and come back better and you
can do it without wallowing in regret or
if you watch me and you say
that could be me tomorrow then
then change
and that's what i hope people do
tara and andy are joining us now i could
have watched an hour of that
conversation it's so important and it's
going to help people make changes in
their own lives i could definitely
listen to that guy all day long i might
even make all of you listen to me all
day
it was so important to have andy tell
his story because he's such an
inspiration i mean he really shows that
despite everything that's going on
outside of your health right your
personal life that you can still make
changes despite that you know he really
took charge he changed his eating habits
he started exercising worked on stress
how to manage that so i'm so proud of
him and i think he is a real role model
for so many people andy you refer to
your prior self as a gelatinous mess
yeah it was a gelatinous blob
i think that might no because i if you
look at those pictures for me it's not
just it's not just the weight i just i
just thought i look i look back i think
i look so unhealthy in those pictures
and um and that was really eye opening
to me and it wasn't something i
recognized at the time but looking back
i realized that i i had let a lot of
things go what was the hardest change
you had to make
i don't think any i don't think anyone
was char was it was any change was
particularly hard um
i did things kind of incrementally it
started with diet first um and then
exercise stress was sort of the last
thing that i i tackled i would sit with
tara and she'd say how's your stress
level and i'd say well you know where i
work and you know what my family is like
so
but you know that was so that was sort
of the last piece i tackled and i think
what's really important is
you know there's there's going to be
ebbs and flows there's going to be
setbacks and you don't have to be
perfect you just have to be a little
better than you were
before yeah now i know that people in
this region in new york they walk
everywhere but clarify this for me you
walked 10 blocks while you were having a
heart attack yeah and i i ran into a
friend i hadn't seen in years and i was
standing there on the court talking to
her are you holding your chest in there
she said to me what are you doing i said
i better go because i'm actually on my
way to the er because i have chest pains
and her eyes lit up like what
but i didn't i didn't think it was a
heart attack i really didn't this is not
the right thing too yeah
exactly we just we just did a piece
yesterday about a man who didn't get
almost lost his life for not getting
enough uh so doctor
what should people do
if they're having symptoms yeah i mean
the first thing is to really call ems
right and potentially take an ambulance
because bad things can happen walking to
the hospital or even taking a cab you
can get hit by unless you're andy
the superman exactly even as a
gelatinous mess i'm a superman doctor i
was reading that the signs of of heart
health and issues with your heart can
start early on in your teens you can
develop plaque in your arteries so how
early should people be
working on their children to to
establish new habits i mean i have a
five-month-old that's probably too early
but she's not eating salads yet but no
as early as possible i have two young
children as well and you know we teach
them to read the nutrition labels we
talk with them about exercise and this
is really an important point because
it's a misconception that things happen
late right so this first sign the heart
attack is a sign of a process that's
been happening for years so we see
coronary artery disease in teenagers
and so you know andy told me well when i
was a teenager i was eating big macs and
drinking cokes and fries because i was
skinny so there's this perception that
just because you look healthy on the
outside or your weight may be a certain
way that you're not laying down the
groundwork for plaque in your arteries
on the subject on the subject of work
stress i know you do a lot of important
stories we pointed that out and that was
important it's key but i i guess you're
not including among that our handbook
i knew that was coming
no but we did do deep fakes and that was
that was that was very serious sarah
andy thank you so much for joining us
thank you